Then I won Miss Alabama. And then I went
on to compete in Miss America and I won
first runner up.
>> Paige Phillips, Miss Alabama.
>> I got a call from a Hollywood agent that
wanted to sign me up. I ended up in
Arizona living this jet setter life,
entertaining dinner parties after dinner
parties, one famous name after another.
One glass of wine, then two glasses,
then it was three glasses, then it was a
whole bottle. And knock came on the
door. And oh, if I'd known how important
that to 2 minutes was going to be in my
life.
>> Paige, you spent years as a beauty
pageant queen. And you also were Miss
Alabama, the runner up for Miss America.
And then you moved to Hollywood, did
acting. You were you you had the same
agent as who?
>> Liberace.
>> Liberace, the famous pianist player,
piano player. And now you're here with
us because that's not where you ended
up. So, but first of all,
>> how did you end up as a beauty pageant
and in that industry?
>> Well, I was 17 years old. I was
graduating from high school. So, I
graduated and then it's like I want to
go to a Methodist college. It was
Birmingham Southern College. And my
parents were very middle class. Um, and
they couldn't afford to send me. uh they
had a shoe business and um they were
just very middle class and they didn't
you know as far as state aid they didn't
uh you know they made more than what it
would take to get a scholarship but then
going to a private university you know
they couldn't afford that right
>> so I said I prayed about it and I said
Lord what what can I do you know I was
raised Methodist and I wanted to go to
the Methodist college and um I heard
about the Miss Alabama pageant and the
scholarships.
>> So, you know, you didn't even have to
win Miss Alabama to get a scholarship. I
mean, you could win Miss Congeniality.
And
>> what is Miss Congeniality? I'm not
familiar with it. So, what is that?
Well, they made a movie about it. Sandra
Bulock, right? So, it's the one that's
that's the fun one. And the girls all
vote on, you know, their their favorite
Miss Congeniality with the personality.
And so I love to laugh and I thought,
well, you know, I can just go for Miss
Congeniality. That's what I was going
for, right? And uh so, you know, but I I
prayed and I prayed with my youth group.
We were in a um had a youth choir at at
the First Methodist Church in Leeds,
Alabama. And so I prayed about it with
uh our preacher and my boyfriend, Hayes.
Um, and I just felt it was I had a piece
about it that that's what I could do.
And it, you know, you you have to walk
forward in faith. You have to do
something. So, I was going to try that.
And I didn't really have the fancy
dresses, you know, cuz a lot of the
contestants um had, you know, they a lot
wealthier and they had designer dresses
and I had little prom dresses, you know,
from from high school. But
>> you use what you have and God blesses
you with more.
>> Amen.
>> So, and I also had a talent. Um,
>> and you know, all of the the pageantss,
they have the interview, they have the
evening gown competition, they have the
back then they had the swimsuit
competition. They don't do that anymore.
Now, it's an exercise outfit.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> Right. And then, uh, you have talent.
So, I had a talent going back from uh
childhood and my uh my grandfather was a
free Will Baptist preacher and he had
revival a lot and so he asked me um to
uh bring my little puppet and do the
children's portion kind of like the
children's story. Yeah.
>> And so I would share Bible verses and we
would sing with my little puppet. And uh
so I I done that when I was seven and
then I did that all the way to about age
10. Then I sort of be began to think
about other things and I put the puppets
aside and became a a cheerle high school
cheerleader and all that. And so when I
was at the point now to where I wanted
to enter the Miss Alabama pageant, I did
get out my puppets. And that was your
talent.
>> That's right. And I wor worked up a
little routine. Um it was a medley of
southern songs, you know, Dixie Land
stuff, kind of Swany River, all that.
And uh yeah, and so um I I had a friend
that helped me um with little piano
arrangement and he played the p recorded
the piano arrangement and then I
competed and it was at the Birmingham
Jefferson Civic Center. They had I mean
it seated 10,000 people. Oh wow.
>> And back in uh 1980 was the year that I
competed. So that was a just a few years
ago. Right.
>> But um yes. So I um I I just never will
forget that Friday night of competition,
the talent competition when I did my
ventriloquist act and we it was full. It
was like 10,000 people that gave me a
standing ovation. That's awesome.
>> And I was just like 17 years old and
couldn't believe what all was happening.
>> But then I won uh the the Saturday night
that they um announced my name as Miss
Alabama. And that's that's how it all
started. So
>> yeah. No, like it's just such a
interesting world because I know that
there's people that do this from little
age all the way up, right? I mean some
pe some parents I've seen those shows
where
>> TLC.
>> Yeah. they like take it super serious
and I mean it's a competition all the
way through
>> and and even today there you know the
usually they don't win on the first
>> time right
>> I did but that's a very unusual um and
and it's it's now they have um Miss
America teen they didn't have that back
when I competed
>> so you were like college age right
>> I was it was I think 17 and the age
limit It was 25 I believe back then.
>> So what is the teenage nowadays? Like
12.
>> So it I'm you know I'm not sure the
exact um when it starts if it starts at
13 14 but it's much younger then.
>> Yeah. Yes. And but that's the teenage
portion and then they've got you know
the miss the the regular um
>> Gotcha.
>> Yeah.
>> You had that Alabama charm. That's
>> Well, I don't know. I think it was uh it
was definitely the Lord because I I had
never done anything like that and it was
just amazing how how it um you know it
was like I went into the interview and
it was like I knew what what it was just
so amazing how it was like was that me
talking
>> because I answered all of the questions
just spot on and you don't know what
they're going to ask you. Yeah.
>> So yeah. So, you got your scholarship?
>> I did. I did.
>> And it covered all your years.
>> Well, so I I won the a full scholarship
to Birmingham Southern College.
>> That's awesome.
>> And then I went on to compete in Miss
America and I won first runner up
>> to Miss America. Pretty high up. That's
that's like there's two left on stage,
you know, and they're looking at each
other and you know and so but I I love
my Miss America sister Susan Powell that
won. Yeah.
>> Um and we are still uh talk to this day
and I'm just so um I made so many great
friends and I won even more
scholarships, Keith. Wow.
>> So that was a that was a huge thing and
it was enough scholarship money to take
me all the way to the master's level.
>> Awesome. Wow. So, um,
>> that is cool. Very nice.
>> So, I know we've kind of talked prior to
recording the show and you said, like
you just mentioned, like there's a lot
of really good things that came out of
this and and good experiences and good
connections, but was this an environment
that you feel like was really bringing
you closer to Christ? What's the balance
between that? Well, at that time,
remember I told you I was raised
Methodist and um
>> I uh you know, I still had I was a a
baby Christian on milk, right? You know,
and I still had uh to understand so many
things and that I didn't understand at
the time. Um, but I I was able to use
the pageant as a platform
>> to talk about Jesus,
>> to talk about how Jesus answered my
prayers to get to get scholarships. And
I was able to um travel around, it was
about 8 to 10 churches uh a month. And
you know I would I would go to
banquetss, widows banquetss and
Valentine banquetss and all these you
know different things apart from the
regular Sunday and Wednesday nights.
>> Um so it it was it was very good for
that. Um and you know everybody's at
different levels of sanctification. So
with the light that I had at the time I
was able to use it for the Lord.
>> Amen. you know, and um you know, as time
went on, um and I don't know if you want
me to jump to before and after, but now
now that I'm an a a Seventh Day
Adventist,
uh my you know, God changed my heart and
had me view things differently.
So, um I have so many good things to say
about my pageant experience and the
scholarships that it provided. Um, but
as I look back, it did lead me down the
road to a worldly road and materialism
and that's where I ended up.
>> Um, God gives us choices and we get to
decide, you know, and I made some very
bad choices.
>> So, he gave me a platform and then
>> all I can say is it it can lead to
idolatry. you know, it can lead to
wanting more. Hey, that was fun. And I
got to to see the world. I traveled all
over uh Germany and Italy with the USO
troop.
>> Um that was back then, you know, they
had the Bob Hope, Miss America, USO
tours. And so that was exciting to to
see Europe and I wanted to see more. You
know, it was like you get a little taste
of that and and you want more
>> and it can lead to that kind of um
desires that are opposite of where God
wants you to go.
>> Yeah. While it is something that it
sounds like in your case it worked out
because God had a plan for your life and
he was meeting you where you were at.
>> Is it something you would generally
recommend to young parents who are like
well you know my kid could probably do
well in a beauty pageant.
>> Is that something is that a road you
would recommend generally for people or
would you
>> well I caution them otherwise
>> as as a Seventh Day Adventist now I see
things differently.
>> Right.
But who am I to say where somebody else
is on their journey?
>> Good answer.
>> So somebody else with the light that
they have, God may be building up
something to lead them just like he did
to me into greater truth.
>> Yeah. When you went to Hollywood,
what did you end up doing there? And
again, your your manager or what do you
call it? Your
>> agent. He was the agent of Leprachi as
well and he said, "Hey, you should." In
fact, you actually told me that he was
also considering you for Las Vegas,
right? To do the puppetry in Las Vegas,
but you ended up going to Hollywood.
>> Yes. Yes. So, I I uh I I did go to
Liberace's uh um place in Las Vegas and
I entertained at the theater there. Um
and I also did a lot of commercials um
in Yes. and and also just um
commercials, you know, just like L'Oreal
and various commercials, you know, you
audition for these commercials.
>> Is that the ones where I mean, I don't
know what it was like back then, but now
we see the commercials where they have
like the hair and is that kind of what
you did
modeling almost.
>> Yeah, like modeling. And so that's how
you kind of in between the you remember
where you get the you get your little
flyers, you know, and oh here's one and
then oh make decent money or was it just
like scraping by?
>> Well, I think it's more scraping by
most of these jobs are.
>> Yeah. Now I had um I had some of some
scholarship money that you can actually
use to further your career as well. So,
um but I did mostly um you know the
commercials because they paid um they
paid more
>> and um but you know after a a period I I
just it was empty. It I just didn't feel
Jesus there. It was uh it was very um I
want to say a lot of I saw a lot of
drugs
>> um you know just immoral uh things going
on and and again it was normal to them.
>> It was normal but it was shocking to me.
>> I mean I didn't know I didn't even know
Yeah. I mean I would have to also
audition for Well, I went to acting
school.
>> Okay.
>> So the agent right the agent Yeah.
they encourage you to do that because
you know um most of getting the job is
is being comfortable in an audition. I
mean you're uncomfortable in the
audition you're probably not
so they want you to be you know they'll
they'll often
encourage you to train.
>> So I drove to Burbank to I think it was
Scott Arthur Allen. He was the big coach
back then
>> and um and I took acting classes and you
know then of course during the breaks
you'd see people you know doing all
kinds of drugs and
>> really yeah
>> plays they were doing drugs while so
that they could perform better on the
acting.
>> Yep. Just just uh taking their hit and
going back in. Um do you see that?
>> Yeah. There's a lot of weed um you know
that that cocaine.
>> Yeah. Cocaine and and and things. I
mean, cocaine definitely if you're
involved in the club scene and that kind
of world and that's, you know, the kids
are social at night time. So, you have
to leave your days open and and you're
going on auditions all night. So, it it
really leaves your work environment or
anything like that in the evening and
it's like that's when you get in
trouble.
>> But, see, Bear Bryant, Coach Bear Bryant
was right when he said, "I don't think
you'll fit in. I don't I don't think
you'll I didn't even know how to smoke a
cigarette,
>> you know." So, you never got involved
with this stuff. I know you did, but you
didn't. You were like, I don't
>> Well, I No, I I did my acting classes,
you know, for several months. And um but
uh
>> But I mean, like, you never got into the
drugs and the smoking.
>> Oh, no, no, no. I it it frightened me.
I knew that I was, you know, it it did
not become normal to me. It was very
>> In your acting classes, did they ever
ask you to do very inappropriate things
during the class? Well, uh, I turned
down a few things, but and then that
they asked me to smoke in a scene, which
was hysterical because I didn't know how
to smoke. So, you can imagine like
popping up a store.
>> Yeah. How how funny that was. I did not
look like the cool, you know, this woman
that this, you know, that had um been
around a bit, you know.
>> But I wonder if these things were just
breaking and chipping away at our
morals, you know what I mean? like like
often these classes um you know it's
sold to you that that you're going to do
these things just so that you can learn
but
>> I remember you know often you're
repeating the things that you see in
either movies or television and yeah I
mean classic case you know here you've
never done this before smoke this you
know it's like
>> you're kind of like you're you're kind
of like giving yourself a reason to do
it because it's just a class it's just
an acting thing and
>> and it seems harmless. Yeah. Seems
harmless and it it really morality.
>> It's just Satan's way of little by
little chimp away little by little.
>> Did you go to Hollywood after you
graduated college? Was it?
>> No. So I um I I did two years at
Birmingham Southern College and then I
didn't finish there and I made the
decision to go to Hollywood.
>> And I knew that I could always go back
and you know use my scholarships. Yeah.
>> Um, so I ended up finishing college
after I had married the real estate
developer in Arizona. I went to I
finished at Arizona State University and
I got a undergraduate in Spanish
literature. Oh wow.
>> And then I went to law school there. So
I got a law degree at uh at Arizona
State University as well. It's called
Sandra de O' Conor College of Law now.
So
>> Okay. So, you know, I as I say, it led
me to the world and I ended up u
marrying um someone that was not in I I
wasn't in God's perfect plan,
>> but he even though we make mistakes,
uh he's merciful.
>> Amen.
>> He's gracious.
>> Yeah.
>> And he he protects you.
>> And he protected me. But I it led to a
life in Arizona. I married a real estate
developer. It was a jet setter life.
>> And um and so it it it you know it
sounds like oh you had everything.
>> You know isn't that great? Don't you
want you know you should enter a pageant
and then that'll lead you to here and
there. But I'm here to tell you that it
was a very um empty life right
>> for me out there spiritually. And so,
um, you know, I but I can't I can't
all I know is now my title
>> is I'm a child of the most high God. I
carry that title and I'm looking for the
crown of righteousness.
>> Amen.
>> That's the crown I want because what is
it that uh Paul said in 2 Timothy 48?
Um he said he's not only going to get a
crown of righteousness but
>> ran the race
>> but but it will be given to all those
who have loved
>> his appearing. I I liked your answer
because you know you were at a place at
the time in the beauty pageantss where
this was the light you had you know
because now like like you know many
Christians would think oh like swimwear
should we but but that's like but that's
where all you knew and you were using it
to God's glory as you knew and I think
that's the beauty of it that God God as
the Bible says he judges according to
light that we've been given yes and he
loves everybody you no matter where
they're at. And and I bet you there's
going to be Christians in heaven who,
you know, did the beauty pageant thing
and love the Lord. And they might not
have really been had the opportunity to
really be like, you know, maybe this is,
like you said, um um, you know, desiring
more worldliness in the long run or all
these things. And so I think that's the
beauty of God.
>> They could have made different choices
than I made and stayed closer to the
Lord, you know, and did not drift. But
uh again, God gives us that those
choices and he gives us uh
>> the more that we draw close to him, the
more light we have, right? And u but
sometimes we have to hit rock bottom.
>> And I had to hit rock bottom.
>> So you were in Hollywood for one year.
Was the reason you left because it was
just like so immoral? Was it like the
Holy Spirit speaking to your mind?
>> Yeah. Well, actually it was less than a
year, but it wasn't a full year. But,
uh, yes, I was very, um, I just knew
that it was Satan's territory, right?
>> And I was right there in the middle of
it. And Coach Bryant was right. I did
not belong there.
>> And I knew then as I looked back too,
that that was God's warning
>> that this is not
>> this is not. But um I was just about
ready to I told my agent I said I don't
like it here and I I really need to go
back to Alabama.
>> And he said well he said I'll tell you
what there is a huge event that's coming
up and I really really want you if you
can just do this one event. It was a big
fundraiser for the Israeli soldiers back
then
>> and he said um they were honoring
Lucille Ball and they had all these
famous people up there. Um, and he said,
"I'm gonna introduce you to some very
important people that can really help
you
>> in your career. So, just don't don't
give up just yet."
>> And I thought, "Okay, well, I'll I'll go
to this since he wants me to." And there
I met the real estate developer,
>> right?
>> Um, so he was sitting at another table,
but um, anyway, we um, we met and he
really didn't like Hollywood either.
in common. Yeah. And so then, you know,
he said, "Well, are you doing anything
this weekend? Like to go to Disney
World?" And, you know, so we um we
really connected and I I admired his um
success early on. Um I mean, he was just
very successful.
>> You you called him the Donald Trump of
Arizona, right?
>> Yeah. He he he was quite uh brilliant at
real estate
>> and had a lot of early on in his early
uh 20s he was a multi-millionaire
and so
>> anyway um but he was down to earth and
he was funny and um so we began to date
and I told him I said but I'm moving I'm
not staying in Los Angeles. So it was
easy to go from Phoenix to Los Angeles
right? I said, "No, I'm going to
Alabama." So, I guess, you know, we just
need to break up. Now, you have to
understand that before I even went to
Hollywood, I broke up with Hayes,
>> my high school sweetheart, and
>> who was also a Christian.
>> Yes. The one God put me with, right?
Another bad decision.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So I told um you know real estate
developer I'm moving and so I guess you
know it's nice nice knowing you but I'm
out of here
>> and I moved back to Alabama. Well, he
said, "I can fly back from Phoenix to
Alabama and we can continue to date."
>> And I said, "Well,
>> okay then."
>> And that's what what he did. And back
and forth and and then before you, you
know, in about 6 months, we were engaged
>> and u and then married. Cool.
>> So, um I ended up, you know, living that
that lifestyle.
break.
>> Hey, subscribe to
If you want to learn Spanish, a great
way will be watching our videos for
practice.
you know, getting into this, I I I think
it speaks volumes when you see they
chose somebody that um was just
genuinely innocently like approaching
it. You know what I mean? Miss Alabama
pageant.
>> Yeah. Like you came you came to the
table um with a motive and and that is
kind of like, you know, I I I really
would love to go to college and and and
that's why I'm here. And and it's like
we're drawn to that. We we like that,
you know.
And and I think that um you know looking
back over your path like you said can
easily get steered down a road. What
would you have advised or maybe given to
somebody that that might be starting out
might be involved in this maybe haven't
gone down a bad road? What would have
steered you down a different road? Well,
I think it it comes down to um waiting
on the Lord and learning how to listen
to his voice instead of um the arm of
flesh
>> because the arm of flesh will fail you.
>> And I after my year as Miss Alabama, I
did commercials with um Coach Bear
Bryant.
>> He's a pretty famous football coach,
right?
>> University of Alabama. Coach Bear
Bryant. Everybody knows him. And uh I I
did the Lorch Diamond commercials with
Coach and we um became, you know, we had
a friendship. He was just a great uh
great man. He encouraged so many young
people.
>> Um and I got a call uh from a Hollywood
agent that wanted to um sign me up. And
so that was exciting. And as you ask
about, you know, what would you advi?
Well, I was all into
Hollywood. What they want to sign me up.
He saw me on national television. Uh my
family thought it was a great idea.
Friends, oh, this is a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity.
>> But back to Coach Bryant, he was
retiring and he asked me to sing at his
retirement party. And so I did. And
afterwards, I had time to talk to him
about it. And I said, "Coach, what do
you think about me moving to Los Angeles
to Hollywood?"
>> And he said, "I don't think that's a
good idea, Paige."
>> He said, "The people in Hollywood are
just not like we are here in Alabama."
>> It they have a different way of life.
>> You don't understand it. It's a
different way of life than what we have.
>> I didn't really understand what he meant
>> cuz you'd never been there.
>> I'd never been there. But that way of
life out there is well I found out it
was it was corrupt. It was morally
corrupt. And you know you do something
wrong for so long that it becomes
normal.
>> And that's basically what what it is out
there. You know they don't think
anything of it.
>> So what drew you to Hollywood? Was it
the glam? Was it the fame?
>> I think it goes back to Keith's question
about and and um Scotty's question. It
was uh you know trusting in what other
people were saying to do. This is a
once-ina-lifetime opportunity. You'll
you may never get this again,
>> right?
>> You know, and you can always finish your
your education or you can always, you
know, do these other things that you
want to do, but take advantage of this.
>> I think it would be easy in your
position to see like, well, this one
door opened up in a big way.
>> Maybe this is another open door for me.
Exactly. And I prayed about it though
and I did not have a peace.
>> What a
>> I did not have a peace and then I prayed
about it and I kept praying and uh and I
waited. I did. At first I did not just
accept the Hollywood agents offer. Um
and I kept praying about it and then I
believe God was using Coach Bear Bryant
as a warning because he will not leave
his children in the dark. He he he knew
that coach Bryant could get my attention
>> and and it did make me stop and think,
should I do this? And I kept praying,
>> but in the end it was, you know, my
family members, this is a great
opportunity. That's hard
>> and all that. And that's the arm of
flesh, trusting in the arm of flesh over
because I I never did have that peace.
>> Why did they want you to go out there
besides it being a good opportunity? Oh,
well, I mean, you know, I think
>> you're proud of your kids, you know,
like
>> and just a little small hometown girl
and you know, and it was just kind of
>> um you know, a lot of u and and some
probably wanted to be an actress
themselves, you know, and you you get
the that
>> right. Right.
>> But in the end, I I did not listen to
the Lord, right?
>> I did not wait on the Lord. I made the
decision and then prayed about it and
basically asked God to rubber stamp it.
>> Yeah. You know, it's funny how many
people have the um Balum experience,
right? Lord, let me go curse him. Uh no.
Oh, well, come on. I mean, there's there
might be like, you know, something that
we can, you know, there's there's some
bad people there that that we can, you
know, do this to. And we we make deals
with God, right?
>> I can't tell you how many deals I made
with God. like if you just let me book
this part I will give you all the money
>> because you worked in Hollywood too all
the money and you just ask and you ask
and you ask and you ask like you know
and and and it's like um after a while
it you know how many different ways can
God actually tell us are we actually
truly inquiring of God do you want me to
do this
>> yes
>> and I think that in in in my experience
as well it's like I I don't think God
wanted me to go to Hollywood but he
certainly used that experience and when
I surrendered to him. Now, it's like,
you know, I I I can give people an
experience that I had and and hopefully
steer them clear of that. And in your
case, that that I I I'm assuming that
that's what, you know, God has opened
the door now for you to say, "Hey, this
was my experience,
>> you know, and I had made some choices
here that maybe you might not want to
do, you know, think about these things."
And so,
>> yeah,
>> you know, God can use it to his glory,
but I don't think he necessarily desires
for us to go into the lion's den. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And I had to learn how to wait on
the Lord's answer
>> because when you don't have that peace
>> Yeah.
>> And then you don't proceed. You wait
until you get the green light from your
heavenly father.
>> Right.
>> I'm curious. Did
did all of that start to become
your identity? What I mean by that is,
you know, when people go when they
pursue certain types of work, beauty,
pageantry, acting, whatever,
>> did your self-image start to become your
identity?
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's part of it. That's
that as I said, it can it can lead to
idolatry in in that way.
um you know you all of a sudden and that
can be addictive.
>> People want more. So if they if they you
know win Miss Alabama and then first
runner up and and then Hollywood you see
the
>> big thing I could steps up
>> and uh
>> I can think of rub my ego for sure. Just
be honest like I'd be like
>> I think that's how it is for most of the
people that are out there. I'm sure, you
know,
>> but when God changes your heart, you
know, you have a different title
>> and all of a sudden you're a child of
the most high
>> and your spiritual eyes are opened.
>> You know, it just is amazing how you see
things differently. Yeah.
>> You see yourself differently.
>> And and another thing is that you don't
trust yourself anymore.
>> You die to yourself. You start to die
daily to you know you want your thoughts
to be God's thoughts. You want your
emotions to be God's and your will to be
God's. Those three things that's the fle
the soul you know please control who I
am because I want my identity to match
with the character of Jesus.
>> Yeah. And I don't think there's anything
wrong with the desire to be want to be
liked or affirmed. I mean, obviously
that's what what drives social media,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, if you think about it, why do
you think God felt like he needed to
affirm this is my son whom I'm well
pleased? You know, it's like
>> we as human beings, we need that
validation.
I think um you know there's a lot of
people in Hollywood that if if you talk
to them like some of the reasons why
they were there, maybe they came from
broken homes or needed that validation.
I know I certainly did.
>> That was one of the reasons that that
drove me to that. So it's like once you
get a little bit of validation then it's
like you crave it and then you you you
tend to do things or make mistakes
>> based on you know
>> or you make choices that you normally
wouldn't have. Let's put it that way.
>> Yeah.
>> There's somebody close in my life that
was put in beauty pageantss from a young
age and I saw
how that became a
kind of focal point in their life. I
mean, they didn't stay in in that. I
mean, they just tried young a few times
and I don't remember how successful.
Seems like they got runner up or
something, but you could see that was
kind of a focal point as they grew
older. It's what that's where people
it's what people emphasized in their
lives was their looks. Mhm.
>> Mhm.
>> But you think about how that over time,
you know, we we're going to get to a
point where we don't look the same.
>> Yeah.
>> We age, beauty fades.
>> It's like if that's all your identity
is, and and you see it with a lot of
these reports that come out of,
>> you know, young girls, they get caught
up in earning money. I was reading a
news story the other day, but a a young
lady, she needed she needed money for
her teeth. She I mean she wind up
spending like $24,000 in dental because
she just had such bad teeth. Like she
was always at the dentist.
>> And she used her your youth and vitality
to earn that money by a guy who wanted
somebody he could have as a we'll say an
extra friend. M
>> um you know and and there's so many
young ladies I see in particular they
they they see
>> that part of their life you know that
becomes their identity their looks their
>> shape their their fa you know the beauty
of their face whatever and
>> it becomes a means to an end it's really
sad
>> it is
>> but yes
>> if it's focused on or emphasized too
much I think that's where it starts to
send people down
>> roads where they make bad decisions How,
Paige, do a lot of these girls end up?
Do you know kind of the path of the ones
that have maybe gotten more success in
those areas? I mean, does it
>> Well, I I know a lot of them that are um
wonderful Christians
>> and uh uh I have very I'm very close to
a lot of them. Um and so, you know, they
have beautiful families. Uh they love
the Lord. um they're living their lives
in a beautiful way. You know, it's all
about choices. Um and also influences
because Satan can use people very close
to you
>> to um make you go in Satan's way and not
God's way,
>> you know, just by wanting to please.
>> Yeah.
>> Wanting to uh affirmation as you said.
So, um it goes back to to choices and
but I know a lot of successful um former
um Miss Alabama's and um Miss Americas
and u so I I have a lot of respect for
uh for these people. I just speaking
personally
um just made
choices that were not in alignment with
God's will
>> and I ended up in Arizona um living this
jet setter life as I said
>> entertaining dinner parties after dinner
parties Barry Gwater came into our home
John and Cindy McCain uh were regulars
and we would go to their home as well
>> right
>> um William F. Buckley. I mean, I just
one famous name after another. Um, and I
lived that kind of life and it was it
was empty. And I almost got to the point
to where, you know, I was just I was
just miserable inside.
>> I had everything money could buy,
>> you know, a beautiful huge home mansion
in Arizona and then a home in England
>> in the New Forest area. And so I had all
this stuff, but I was very very um
empty. And one day
>> is that when you hit rock bottom that
No, that's not it.
>> God is merciful and he has a I had to go
through a long journey, Keith. I mean,
this is just amazing. It's like I wish I
had been a fast learner, but I I have to
admit I was a slow learner here. Uh but
one day and when I was preparing for yet
another dinner party and I'd just given
one, you know, a couple of nights prior
and um we were having a political event
at at our home. Um and a knock came on
the door and it was two Adventist
teenagers. They knocked on my door and
they gave me that copy of The Great
Controversy.
>> Link in the description for a free copy.
>> Yeah. And so when and they were at my
door for a couple of minutes and invited
me to their church. They were so nice
and u after they left I flipped through
the book and and I thought this is a
great book. I I don't know a lot of this
history and I like history you know
>> it's like church history Christian
history.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The reformation history.
>> Exactly. The dark ages. teach you that
and I mean a smattering but in college
but not much.
>> So um I
>> I flipped through the book and then I
put it in a box because I was busy
>> and I forgot about it
>> and then it stayed in that box and I
went through um I was married
>> see 12 years out there anyway. uh went
through a divorce and it was uh
unfaithfulness and I had a biblical
reason to leave. So u I my two sons and
I traveled back to Alabama
>> from Arizona.
>> From Arizona. That's right. And then um
in time my high school sweetheart um and
I I went through the divorce and my high
school sweetheart and I um Hayes
remember.
>> Oh, so he came back in the picture.
>> Yes. So I I told you he was my boyfriend
during so um so we began to um uh pray
together and he uh introduced me to the
Baptist church and
>> so he was Baptist.
>> Yes. And I was Methodist and he sort of
made fun of me because I I had been
sprinkled and I needed a proper baptism
but I didn't really understand all that.
I just started joking around to get
dunked.
>> So um anyway, we ended up uh blending
our families. He had a son and I had two
sons and um and I so we married and and
I was baptized in the Baptist church. Uh
we for several years um you know raised
our sons. We went to on Sunday morning,
Sunday evening and Wednesday night. We
had uh Bible studies in the home. Um,
and then you know, our oldest son was
ready to uh, he graduated from high
school and he was ready to go to college
and he he moved all the way to
California,
>> okay,
>> to go to USC.
>> And so
I went through a emptiness nest
syndrome.
>> I I went to the doctor. I said, you
know, what do I do? I'm so depressed.
And
>> um and he um prescribed
an anti-depressant
>> and he also said drink a glass of red
wine every night.
>> Oh
>> yeah. And
>> that's interesting.
>> Yeah.
>> So I had never been on any prescription
medication and I had very little alcohol
um because I had a severe allergy to
alcohol. I could not I would my nose
would swell up. I had headaches. So, I
just didn't have very much at all.
Right. But the anti-depressant
then opened up my head. It was like I
could breathe and the and I could drink
the wine and it didn't even affect me
anymore.
>> So, it was amazing how that, you know,
and so it was an evening glass and my
husband lost his dad and he was going
through a difficult time. So, the doctor
prescribed the same thing. He um had the
Yeah, I know. I
>> take this pill, drink this liquid.
>> Yeah, you'll be
>> fine. Anyway, so the glass of one glass
of wine, you know, it was then two
glasses, then it was three glasses, then
it was a whole bottle. It and it was in
the evening. It wasn't during the day,
>> but still it was an addiction.
>> Yeah.
>> And that led me into um such a horrible
feeling of not being able to control.
>> Mhm.
you were in bondage. You knew you
couldn't stop.
>> And I it went on and on and I'd try to
stop. No, I'm not going to have any wine
tonight. And and I couldn't. I I I
couldn't.
>> I'd never been in that position before.
And that was my rock bottom.
>> Wow.
>> When I went into the backyard
>> and I fell on my knees and I said, "Oh
Jesus, forgive me. Mhm.
>> I have drifted so far from you.
>> I mean, all these years, you know, as a
tender teenager.
>> Mhm. Yeah.
>> I was with you.
>> I was on milk,
>> but I was with you
>> and all these bad decisions
>> and then it led me and again, back to
the doctor that prescribed the
anti-depressant and the glass of wine.
>> What What did I do? I trusted in the arm
of flesh. Yeah.
>> Again, instead of praying and see, I
just didn't have that connection.
>> And I just trusted. I did what the
doctor told me to do.
>> And uh so I heard his voice and that's
when he said, "My child, I have waited
for you to come back."
>> Oh wow.
>> I waited for you to come back. You're
okay.
>> You're okay. You're going to be okay
now.
>> Yeah.
>> I forgive you. I love you. And I'm going
to heal you from this addiction. Mhm.
>> He said, "Just listen to my voice and
follow me.
>> Have faith."
>> And the next day, um, that's when I got
a desire to go upstairs and clean out
the attic.
>> And that's not something that anybody
really wants to do. Um, but
>> especially not after a night like that,
you know.
>> No. I mean, cleaning out an attic is
akin to moving all over again. It's like
boxes everywhere. You don't want to do
that.
But I knew that the Lord wanted me to do
it. Um, and I thought maybe it's I can
give some things away to help people in
need. You know, Salvation Army, there's
clothing. There's all kinds of things.
That's, you know, you have to when
you're drawing close to the Lord, you
know, he calls on you to do certain
things and give. And it's better to give
than receive. And so I um spent about
three hours in the attic.
>> I had three piles of boxes. one was to
keep uh give away and I had a throwaway
box a pile.
>> So about the end of cleaning out the
attic, I saw um a box in the corner and
it was kind of you know how boxes you
pile things on it and it's kind of
dented and battered looking and um and I
thought, "Oh, there's nothing. I can
throw that away."
>> And I I
opened up the box and there was the
great controversy.
>> How many years later was that? It was uh
it was about 25 years.
>> 25 years you've had that book.
>> Maybe your life had to take a
trajectory. Yes.
>> And I and I often say this too because
>> maybe you wouldn't have responded to it
at this point. Like God chose the moment
that he knew,
>> all right, Paige is going to listen at
this point. And like all of a sudden,
boom, you open it up
>> the very next day.
>> And I'll have to say this. See, when uh
when I read the great controversy, I
began to and that was, you know, I had
fallen on my knees in the backyard and
then I found the great controversy. I
began to read. I knew that that was the
reason God sent me to the attic
>> is to read this book finally.
>> It's a great book.
>> Two and a half decades. Finally, is now
it's time for you to read it.
>> Did you read it in the attic?
>> Oh,
>> I know how sweaty those attics I I I you
know flipped through it and I said, you
know, I'm going to read. We got to take
this down to the air conditioning. Yeah.
To the cover to cover. I could not put
it down. I just want to say to those who
are going through a tri, you know,
Satan's going to fight and do everything
he can to pull you back.
But don't give up.
Stay the course and learn how to trust
in the Lord to provide for you, to take
care of you. He will sustain you through
that trial. Don't look at the
circumstances.
>> Don't look at the circumstances. Look at
how good God is
>> and how he's going to take care of you.
But don't give up because if you do, you
will miss the best God has for you.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> In this life and in the life to come. So
stay the course. That's so important to
trust in the Lord. He loves you. He's
given his word that you can rely and
have faith because faith comes from
hearing and hearing comes from the word
of the Lord. and seek that crown of
righteousness, not the earthly, worldly,
material things. Seek that crown of
righteousness and it will be given to
all those who have loved his appearing.
[Music]